[Música]
é essa
a macau e xangai garantiu ronaldo bom
vocês já fui assistir a freira vocês
queriam muito que esse gênero de filmes
que você gosta nessa hipótese o passeio
de ensino a vão assistir um filme de
leonardo de caprio foi um domingo nas
cleide russo ilya mata mata a motiva 3
não sei que é provável demônio eu fui
assistindo já vai ficando gostei já que
agora quando eu esqueça de pedir
explicações esquece clicado gostei de
pescar e faz tempo que não vejo o vídeo
inscrição está recebendo a notificação
que se não clicar em gosto youtube para
de mandar os vídeos
então clica logo gostei e comecei a
ouvir agora já que ela não fez isso não
implica em efeito é chato pra cá na
carreira no cinema pelo cinema é muito
melhor
muitos corpos em 31 espaço para o medo é
uma pessoa má chegando a pipoca o casal
linamara hangu uma criança chupando
nardini e você fica nec mais tranquila
agora em casa na boca poesia motivo para
ficar com medo apenas cenas nossa
cerveja é previsível com esse tipo de
cena não tenho medo não vai por dentro
acaba assim é que pariu [__] que pariu
pela lusa estava no chunnam mais calma é
só ficar tranqüilos até não perceber que
eu tô com medo
a comusa que eu quero tudo e muito
melhor no cinema eu fui no cinema eu
cheguei lá a sala estava lotada de
espírito com que uma alma viva eu sentei
no cinema comer sanduíches além de uma
vida tranquila disse que é nóis aqui um
com um que eu quero é passar o negócio
até adivinha a primeira coisa que passa
antes do filme a freira ou pegadinha do
silvio santos como era pegadinha
contratando segurança para o cemitério
que eu acho que tem mesmo que eu acho
roubo cemitério por mais injusto que tem
no mundo porque a vítima não tem como se
defender quando fiquei sabendo e ninguém
foi roubado no cemitério morto levantou
a romã foi o vila da ponta então eu acho
necessário mas ao emprego que eu não
iria nem eu podia ser limpador de cavalo
um cavalo com caganeira é um puto meu
deus eu só queria mais um outro emprego
que eu saí desse emprego e limpador de
cavalos eu isso a oi caiu emprego e de
segurança desse critério que é reserva
também querem palco do cavalo na gente
pelo amor de deus não posso deixar
estava aqui você possui a criança vai
subir no carro mas se ela na merda do
cavalo pode cavar aqui pode escorregar
na merda de recusar um negócio um quer
um testículo cara aí que eu e tu é doido
se já aconteceu na casa da gente um
vulto boneca que se mexe batia na
criança chupa narguilé e não vai
acontecer no cemitério que eu acho que é
o ponto de encontro para qualquer coisa
espiritual que venha a este mundo a
galera maior cemitério galera meia-noite
na catacumba do seu pedro góis imitar
não a única coisa boa que tem cemitério
você ficar olhando a data que a pessoa
nascer e morrer para saber se ela morrer
novo que você olha o nome da pessoa
neide tem nasceu em 1930 faleceu 1943
trezeano neide com 13 anos não existe a
próxima de mim e cemitério nem de 13
anos nem fábrica ouvir muito e não de
ver que é por isso que vou mudar meu
nome é a constância eu faço apostas e os
cheiros e 12h pereira da silva é vida
pergunta instância pereira da silva dos
santos neto batista nunes como é que a
pegadinha uma criança que passa no
cemitério e chamas só aí já caminha com
a pegadinha acaba comigo ali já eu sou
segurança aqui o segurança viu e
roubaram filha da [__] aqui o satanás
que têm vez não olha deus
essa passa eu fui a criança possa pessoa
vê e o povo vai pedir também para cá
para morrer leite é comigo passou a
criança diz veio começa a rezar tanto
tanto que maria para essa tarde me
dirijo a não olha vai nela que nosso
filme jacob que o nome baseado em fatos
reais e eu quero que o filme era um
castelo é também onde a pessoa mora num
castelo cheia de teia de aranha o
negócio reis em um negócio lucas e olhos
e fala não é de deus aí tem duas foram
no porte e dizendo não sei se ele será
que eu entro gente eu preciso entrar e
eu pensando entra num entra e quem sabe
não quero que tinha na por não falha
vênus 6 será que o erro será comum e eu
disse a minha senhora vai se deitar
aspecto de sharja tomou seu carro
entrando b12 ela na porta do meu amigo
se houver sumiu se numa velocidade que
eu nem vi o que é na hora eu pensei meu
deus não sabe que o diabo o sonic do
nada aparece na porta de 50 sempre pega
chave pega a chave d
acho que é assim
não sei você mas sim eu acho que essa
senhora morreu ea outra que pegou a
chave e sai correndo e também do quarto
pega uma porta-voz do pescoço pula e
morre um mito não começou a filmar o
capitão chutou a outra ponta do castelo
capeta cultura e no outro dia um cara
vai no castelo levar mantimentos para
treinar ele chega pra lá a mulher é
morta pendurada ele aí fica aquela
tensão e olhando 5 corpo além do castelo
e entendo que alguma coisa pode ter
acontecido índio de discutir a galera
não to com medo não era nada nós vamos
passar em que voaram era [__] nenhuma
todo mundo morrem de susto o cinema e as
almas até lá no canto cinema ou e perfil
e é aí que começa o filme entendeu que
houve uma morte no lugar de freire um
lugar que passei de santo entendeu que
eles fazem eles no outra freira e um
padre palavra poder investigar o negócio
é ganhar aguarde 62 gordy e não chama
quem sabe
sempre a pessoa quer resolver o problema
no chão com a prova a galera autorizada
a fazer isso chama a polícia chama swat
no chama o escolhido eu que são pessoas
preparadas e sou eu no comando caso este
morreu gente ali e tá então vamos sair
todo mundo isola área 20 anos depois mas
o ipo que tem aquela área de 20
quilômetros isolado alívio não morreu
gente lá na paella mas senhor era tão
grande a fazer coro à venda é por isso
que o app também sei que todo lugar
também pra vocês também para o capítulo
pode ter um castelo e também fala coisa
ali a tentar lhe chama escola visão não
vão pra lá um padre e uma freira poder
investigar o caso e fazer as pessoas não
perderem a fé é a igreja que eu acho uma
besteira eu acho que ninguém quer perder
a festa porque o satanás matou o bebê e
matou a moça está morando ali agora
cards também acho que seja o motivo
perder até porque só porque o satanás
palavrão aí o padre ea freira vou na
casa para que foi levar mantimentos que
achou frio lá coisa no curso eles vão lá
o padre a freira e um carro bonito vão
de charrete chegou a hora que o carro
para ele não quer mais dar lhe o padre a
freira gente que brinca no seu cavalo
para o cara é o cara não cavalin pankow
porque tem medo de passar por aqui nunca
passa por aqui o que a galera decide não
vamos caminhando
a gente vai caminhar aqui normal uma
satanás bumbum seu cavalo parar não vai
meu deus confira os animais cara ele
sabe das coisas quem é que acha a droga
é o cachorro ser humano faz o que cheira
lambe chupa a droga tem que confiar nos
animais seu carro defendeu
não não vai só no cavalo volta eles vão
caminhando chegando mais perto a ver que
não é de deus eu já vi desde o começo do
filme que não era de deus que o negócio
aí tudo cinza não tem uma janela aqueles
passarem henrique que mata pessoas do
que eles passarem que fica num morto com
um bico boi é bem no icv a ruindade do
animal de penico no ano na barra morreu
está sofrendo na ruindade não é tão
grande que ele fica se eu vou cega o
humor que o nome corpo me ficou agora
pomba legal bomba é bonitinho fala pai
joga pombo velho vai pra alimentar a
quem as pombas acaba na zaga ele falou
que tinha bomba pra corvo pai porque
chama coisa ney defendeu o chamdo
reboques de boxe das pessoas
14 anos ele chega lá e vai mostrar para
ele o corpo da mulher que ele botou lá
dentro ele guardou porque está com medo
da barney de comer o hotel e ligeiro no
castelo a ficar bonita indicou assim não
tem uma janela simulou uma geladeira com
um pingo em cima do executivo é ligar na
porta tem nada é só aquela coisa é assim
que não lhe mostra o corpo só que o povo
da frente a assentar ele falou eu quero
é não deixar esse concentrado não deixa
ele deitado e eu pensando o cavalo disse
que a volta você for maluco realizou um
lugar que a freira estado enfocada ele
olha a corda olha para baixo e ver o
sangue fica num sangue é sangue novo de
filme é povo também é que [__] merda
olha o negócio e acorda meu negócio no
chão biel que nossa será que é tudo diz
o provérbio é sangue bull exemplo é uma
mulher comum de pano na cabeça fazendo
com apoia e sinhá galera olha nada na
frente tudo bom
como é que está a pôr dentro está assim
a com um zagueiro
aí o padre fala assim galera sem licença
para conversar com ela ea galera da
licença lógico nem se fosse eu toco meu
patrão suor de um desejo tão junto é nós
aí começa a conversar com a ver naquele
ambiente e nojenta campeão então
lanterna tem uma lâmpada tem um ano
saída e entrada de ar fica agoniado
desacato ao saber que a record vai bem
eu queria conversar com a senhora amanhã
podemos ter um médico de um amor dessas
isto é o demônio que o pai concorda não
tá bom vou dormir aqui também agradável
que fosse eliéser não satanás é essa
senhora é só para tomar muito tempo que
morreu na hora que eu queria saber se
você vai morrer mais foi já comunicada
galera mas não incomodou não aí o cara
bonitão que saiu né poupada ficar
conversando com a velha e está
caminhando é ir lá em direção ao carro
ao top 10
embora o nada passou a freira caminhando
na frente dele eu amigo era perigoso
ficar cinco minutos correndo assim no
mesmo lugar só escorregando em cima da
meta aí do nada é uma gotinha cine lapa
quando cai a gotinha que ele olha pra
cima
ela tá em cima dele com a corda para
enforcar ele assim fosse comigo eu
consegui me focar para ficar
escorregando em cima da meta também a
freiras o homem era só uma visão e ele
levantando uma senhora normal meu deus
do céu que loucura loucura esse lugar do
curu e o padre nisso toda você não pode
estava dormindo lá no mundo que ele
achou até 15 este ano aquele castelo na
rádio rádio começou a tocar o everton
quando em que o demônio bom ator mas que
esse impasse está é só o coração sp e
essa o coração fica assim ele não estava
fadado a aquisição da companhia mas
ainda mais apoio mas agora já o botafogo
então não é que o padre faz elevando
falou que será isso aí vou investigar
seu nome de madrugada ligou o rádio e
ficar aqui vou curtir também essa beleza
no spotify levantar um cai cai levanta
pago na tentação de comer aquela
perseguição idiota de filme de terror
que passa alguém por trás um estranho
quer sair é estranho nada pode senti um
dedinho nas costas de um estranho ele
olha pela janela lá embaixo eu queria
assim ocorrendo é que ele faz ele vai
atrás do menino de 4 gato você diga não
vai desgraça essa criança não é de deu
uma criança que passa correndo à noite
sorrindo não é de deus a criança sozinha
aqui gente que o pai dessa criança meu
deus é o padre vai correr atrás do
marcador o menino sumiu ele é possível
negócio é só a cabecinha domingo passado
ele é por baixo das suas pernas domingo
passado pensa no dia do saci está todo
dividido o episódio é aí do nada
empurrou para o pai cai de um caixão que
a tabela do turno já fechou a porta já
em terra pro pato no tucupi apresentar a
minha água gás e bueno disse que era pra
correr atrás de mim mesmo e gabriel
cavallo a oni paula bem tranquilo porque
não foi a menina feira que foi falar
acorda no meio da noite e resolve dar um
foguete filme assim a corda meia-noite
um lugar que já morreu gente satanás
está por aí a pessoa pensa por que não
anda a meia noite r conhecer novos
lugares respirar novos ares de repente
contra o capeta por aí fala aí que eu
peso tudo bom carol rapaz tranquilo aqui
ó e não ficando por questionar não
gostou perigoso em lousada também vai
cantar mas eu não quero aqui eu tô até
mansouri lá então pronto vamos encontrar
por esse encontro valeu ela entrou
dentro da igreja o negócio escuro tudo
feio uma velhinha se não tem janela fica
alinhada que não tem janela lugar bom
tempo de janela vai caminhando e do nada
uma sombra começa a aparecer na parede
da freira assim ela vai crescendo
crescendo a sombra vai crescendo
crescendo crescendo muito grande é tão
grande eu fico pensando meu deus isso é
uma freira é um transformer ea sombra
vai andando vai entanto na hora que
entra na frente do espelho quando entra
no espelho se transforma na freira ea
freira ficou olhando assim pra elas têm
diferentes iberdrola estela sai do nada
um susto do [__] que eu tomei porque
foi um susto muito diferente e estou
acostumado a ver coisas na frente do
espelho atrás nunca vi ela sai correndo
que a desgraça e já escutou o grito do
padre corre cava encontro padre e abre
elas alvo para uma pizzaria na noite de
natal a norma conversando com seria aí a
paz como é que tá ela fala pô o cara que
é agitada noite né ela conversando com
as freiras prova começa a contar não é
que nesse lugar aqui um cara já em vôos
até mais aqui mas já está tudo tranquilo
não tem mais nada a ela a então tá bom
mas neste momento tenho a impressão de
que a filha estava assim não é tão então
eu que nasci já pato branco musa que
[Música]
e chega a notícia pra ela que ela não
pode mais sair de lá agora não porque
chegou o horário de oração das freiras e
aí só pode sair no tempo que tem trancar
o portão e ela não portar tranquila que
outros naquele tempo não usa que não tá
bom a gente vai mostrar seu quarto leva
ela para o mesmo quarto que a mulher se
matou ela não tá tranquilo quando uma
que eu trouxe o ivh o trio que o padre
vai conversar com a freira que está com
espancada feira velha está conversando
com a freira do nado pescoço afetar
correu o dia da feira e do nada avança
no cara e comece a brigar 2 e o padre
que braço da feira que eu achei muito
rude muito grosso cara não tem um pingo
de respeito mas vai ficar essa [__]
obrigando nada a minha guitarra dormir
no quarto de max matou acorda 11 do
pesadelo ela olha para trás tem uma
freira resume
cara eu não a situação dessa eu acho que
olhe para cima de deus esquece tudo o
que eu te pedi na vida eu só quero uma
coisa me leva rapaz só assim ea feira
que estava rezando disso aparece do nada
aparece atrás dela
ela olha pra trás sumiu ela passa
correndo atrás
ela já passa pega na corda e pulando da
janela meu deus e se matou ela corre na
janela só chega lá não tem ninguém e não
tem corda nem alguém bate na porta eu
pensei meu deus será alguém será o seu
muro e eu pensando é o satanás não abre
não ela abre a porta
ou as graças atanásio ano disse eu digo
sempre escuto eudes o cavalo de ela sai
correndo pelo corredor chega no final do
corredor de uma porta lab que é instalar
a freira bem bonitinho parecendo chupa
cabra e aos 20 feira desse lado vídeo do
outro começa ás cruz girar as coisas
romã ao pat correr atrás do menino já
abidal e se me dá trabalho e após esse
menino meu tempo nem pedir pelo povo
disse a menina o camg à frente do
satanás lá no céu que já vêm aqueles é
uma chata freire é uma freira na e junto
todas as feiras começa rezado nada
as freiras votto na parede parece um
saco de boxe que só uma que é a menina
que foi para lá nós creio que já estava
lá e ela continua rezando e parra
pancada nas costas ela continua razão e
thá eu acho que nesse momento já está
revendo tudo errado alguma graça fred
freira medida só vai trabalhar para a
faculdade jackson o demônio menino ele
reside em latim o pai foi na tarde o
menino já brunet correndo e do nada um
ao quim deve aparece atrás do painel
em sub todo lenta assim que o zumbi
alento né agora corre para ver quem vai
ver o esqueleto correr na tua vida do
maior rival que deve vai matar o padre
ton militar o rapaz bonito parece
arrancar a cabeça do alto da glória de
deus ea filha chorando [__] pensei
você chegar mas só eu ea feira de
chorando cara eu paguei assim que freei
ela olha para trás e eu tinha feito
nenhum era só ela sempre usando a cabeça
satanás é a freira e na cara do padre
diz assim é padre parece que temos a
conclusão esse lugar não é mais sagrado
acho que eu sou esse papel e olhar na
cara dessa vez dizer sim à che pra mim
era sagrada saque até acham tão
tranqüila abrir um shopping aqui pé eles
comecem a entrar no gasóleo em um lugar
que é sagrado e eles pegam é um negócio
que tem o sangue de jesus dentro dizendo
que eu sou jesus de verdade foi usado
para celular no dia que tem para invocar
o demônio e celular ou com o sangue de
jesus chora deus ainda estão conversando
nada sofreu no sábado nã quarta feira
pega o padre já vem focando assim o
menino tomou na casa da família na sexta
feira pega o menino pelo pescoço enfoca
se joga no chão meu amigo eles ocorrem
na mulher tem o porte escrito deus
termina que eu falei caboca bôlas com o
cabouco tudo satanás vai explodir o
cinema ele sempre se serve para cada um
vai e eu um cara aí que eu me separe eu
vou lá o menino que estava ocorrendo um
filme do direito é muito conhece meu pai
me ajuda a entrar dentro da sala um
lugar cheio de freira de capuz todas
paradas quietas olha no ossinho e olhar
pra cima ia falar é pra isso deus foi
pra isso que eu cheguei até aqui pra
isso tudo isso que eu passei na minha
ansiedade enem já coação precoce a
chegar aqui morrer no final fez aqui uma
sala cheia de freira e seu fim é isso
que eu estou a olhar pode falar o cavalo
disse patriota
já prá nice levanta das águas num
é o menino veio pra symphony of
regionais tô preocupado deixa comer
batata freira feira pega minha pelo
pescoço e começa a levantar se a menina
levanta o sangue de jesus não tem mais
sangue de jesus e as pessoas pensam
nossa ua outra foto nada ela cospe o
sangue na cara da festa
o óleo é deus que jesus pisa na cabeça
dos atuais mais um vez e tem mais um
monte de coisa que eu vou contar que sei
se quiserdes assistiu mas é isso muito
obrigado se você gostou deste vídeo não
esquece clicar em gostei é muito
importante quando eu não peço a vocês
esquecem então clique em gostei aí tá
querendo você comentasse aqui embaixo é
o filme de terror que você mais gosta o
que você acha mais engraçado o filme tem
o que você acha mais estranho comenta
aqui embaixo se inscreve no canal para
não perder de novo e as redes sociais
são essas aqui caso você queira me
seguir ver minhas viagens pelo mundo é
um jogo é nóis além e picchu